[inaudible]
on July the first 1997 after 155 years
of British software and see Hong Kong
returned to China.
It did so as a special administrative
region under the one country two systems
model.
A model whose goal was to ensure that
Hong Kong would continue being Hong
Kong,
the freest city on the entire Asian
continent.
That means that thanks to this
particular political model,
Hong Kong has its own laws,
its own justice system,
its own police force,
its own currency and even has its own
customs and immigration policy that is
very different from the rest of China.
So in the day to day operations of Hong
Kong it will,
it's pretty much as an independent
country and well it's going to remain
that way until at least the year 2047
maybe that's why he's,
since Hong Kong passed into Chinese
hands that things have gone pretty well
in the city over the past 20 years.
Hong Kong's economy has grown by an
average of 3.3%
pay.
Yeah.
More than 1 million people have moved
from mainland China to this territory in
search of fortune and the city is still
an oasis of freedom.
Yes,
the influence and the interference of
the Chinese government's in local
politics has grown a lot in recent
years.
Now here on visual politic,
we already talked about this for
example,
then past videos we discussed the
umbrella revolution and Beijing's
growing interference in local politics
swells the viewer.
In the video.
Today we're going to talk about another
standout feature of this place.
I mean,
did you know that Hong Kong is the city
with some of the most expensive and also
the smallest houses in the world?
Well,
listen up a rising market,
seven and a half million inhabitants and
more than 1,200
skyscrapers,
homes and Hong Kong are terribly
expensive and it's not just homes,
garages,
officers,
and anything else that has to do with
the real estate sector is incredibly
expensive.
So much so that we can find news like
this.
Hong Kong parking spots sold for record,
600,000
US dollars.
All right,
so let's assume that you have $1 million
and you wanted to buy apartments in one
of the cities in nicer areas.
Well,
in that case,
you'd barely be able to afford a 22
square meters or 236 square feet,
and that's for $1 million when
considering cities with the most
expensive premium homes in the world's
Pong Kong places.
Second only behind Monaco,
Alibaba,
chief biases own Aladdin's cave jack mob
purchases.
Hong Kong's most expensive home for 193
million US dollars.
But of course if we take into account,
but all kinds of people live in Hong
Kong and skip and Monica is very
particular case.
Hong Kong is by far the city with the
most expensive homes in the wells.
It's giving you an
idea.
Since 2003 the price of housing in Hong
Kong has risen by 450% and today the
average price per square meter exceeds
$16,000
that's the equivalence of $1,486
per square foot.
Yup.
That means that if you want to buy a
normal 90 square meter house,
nothing particularly fancy,
you have to pay at the very least one
point $5 million,
which is quite the mortgage.
Now,
it's very common to compare which cities
are more or less accessible by counting
how many years of average wages before
taxes we need to buy an average home.
Well,
so let's have a look at Hong Kong.
According to the latest data,
in order to buy a house in Hong Kong,
you'd need more than 18 years of full
wages for comparison in cities like
Tokyo or Singapore,
one needs less than five years of wages.
In other words,
Hong Kong's situation is totally crazy
and not only that,
since prosperity is so expensive and
inaccessible,
the Hong Kong zone citizens,
they've had to buy smaller and smaller
homes.
And speaking of small homes,
could you guess what the average surface
area for a home in Hong Kong,
it's,
what would you guess a hundred square
meters,
80 60 well,
all of those figures are sky high.
The reality is that that's 42 square
meters or 452 square feet.
Can you imagine living in a house that
small?
Well,
in that case,
check out the latest trends.
Hong Kong is so expensive that
architects are building a hundred square
foot tube homes made from concrete water
pipes,
ra,
ra.
So some of you might now be thinking,
well wow,
Simon,
that's really small,
but I'm pretty sure that's because
people live alone in tiny apartments,
which alters the statistics,
right?
Well,
no.
On average,
almost three people live in a 42 square
meter or 425 square feet apartments,
which is pretty darn insane.
And it's not only the homes.
The same thing happens with officers.
Awesome.
Him skyscrapers sells for record of 5.2
billion US dollars.
But of course,
having said that,
you might now be wondering,
well,
why the Hell Oh homes so expensive in
Hong Kong?
Well,
listen up.
The lack of land,
a myth,
massive skyscrapers,
tiny end ludicrously expensive
apartments.
This is how we could pretty much
describe Hong Kong.
Don't you agree?
I mean,
after all,
we're talking about one of the most
densely populated places in the world.
All right,
so many people very,
this'll space pretty much a perfect
combination for super high prices.
Right?
Well,
hold on just a moment because,
well,
this is not the whole truth.
The truth is that less than 25% of that
is a quarter of Hong Kong's territory is
urbanized and only 7% of the entire
territory is occupied by urban housing
outside the crowded areas,
we find countryside,
jungle,
old villages,
golf courses,
and many,
many single family homes.
Oh,
alrighty.
Then so well,
how is this possible?
Why don't you see it?
For years,
Hong Kong was considered to be the
freest economy in the entire world
according to the index of economic
freedom.
We're talking about a place with low
taxes,
free trade,
legal security as a very small amounts
of government intervention.
Yup.
Hong Kong is a highly capitalist city.
That's why it's the third largest
financial center in the world after only
London and New York,
by the way,
fun fact here.
The Basic Law.
Hong Kong's constitution limits the
government so that it can't spend more
than it makes.
This means that the government usually
closes every year with a surplus.
Indeed,
this has led it to save so much surplus
that it has over $220 billion in
reserve.
Yeah.
Unlike many,
many other countries around the world,
Hong Kong does not have public debt.
All right,
but fun facts assigned,
let us continue.
The fact is that despite so much freedom
and so much commitment to capitalism as
a sector in which the government has
intervenes a lot and I am betting
because you've been watching this video
for some time now that you can probably
guess what that is.
Yes,
it is the real estate sector.
You see the government owns practically
all of the lands in Hong Kong.
Governments.
Authorities control how much land is put
on the market and when it can be built
upon and of course if the development
bureau decides what Cam and what cannot
be built now generally lands
concessions.
They're given through auctions.
These are generally for private homes,
offices or commercial uses.
All.
They are done directly through
agreements with developers when public
housing with lower rental prices is
going to be built,
which is where a large part of Hong
Kong's population live
and it's normal even in auctions for the
property to continue being government
property as they are granted a right of
use for an unspecified number of years.
So sure homes being so expensive in Hong
Kong has a lot to do with scarcity but
it's not due to eight geographical
shortage.
It's due to governmental decision
making.
There's plenty of land to develop new
residential and office areas and there's
always the option of gaining ground at
sea.
Yes,
in Hong Kong,
reclaiming land from the sea is not a
strange thing to do.
Indeed a quarter of all the built up
areas of Hong Kong are on land that was
reclaimed from the seat,
but the government,
they decide absolutely everything.
The shortage of land is a myth.
There are over 200 hectares of land
available for building in the urban
areas.
The shortage of housing is real,
but that is because of deliberate
manipulation of the market by the
government.
John Right Barrister and chairman of
Friends of cycle.
Well,
in recent decades,
as we mentioned before,
Hong Kong's population has grown a lot
because many people have come in from
China.
In addition,
family size has decreased and many
Chinese investors want to invest in this
city,
which is known for its legal security.
Hello,
this has led to a rise in demands.
Burton not supply.
This is simply because the government
doesn't want to do it.
Palm prices will continue to grow due to
limited supply.
Thomas Lamb,
senior director at night to frank.
Well now the question has to be,
well,
why is the government interested in
restricting supply and increasing
prices?
Well,
there are at least two reasons.
The first is that auctions are a great
business for the public pass.
In 2017 for example,
one out of every $5 from public revenues
came from the sale of lands and we're
talking here about $15 billion.
The second reason,
which is much more sinister is that
there are suspicions of not very clean
relations between the authorities and
large promoters,
and in some cases,
these suspicions have led to
convictions.
Calm property magnate,
Thomas Kwok back in jail for bribing
cities.
Number two official,
you see the real estate sector in Hong
Kong is held in very few hands,
hands that belonged do
multibillionaires.
In fact,
17 of the 14 biggest estate magnates in
Asia are from this city.
Okay.
And well these big businessmen preferred
to keep prices sky high and avoid
competition.
It's something that happens when the
government brings various Atlanta market
and see in addition increases any new
projects,
bureaucracy that way.
Small and medium sized enterprises,
contents of the market and foreign
companies simply don't dare to because
that have a clear disadvantage.
And of course if you are,
as you might imagine,
all of this has pretty severe
consequences.
The consequences,
the crazy price of housing has meant
that despite having a lot of employments
in high wages,
many people live in difficult conditions
like families having to live in 40
square meters,
that's 431 square feet homes while
paying exorbitant Morgan.
This is
system has also led many people,
especially the youngest ones do depends
on the government's public housing.
And as you might imagine,
these are particularly small and do
remember that in Hong Kong there's no
chance of living on the outskirts or in
remote areas because that would mean
crossing over to mainland China and
losing all of the freedoms that people
have in this city as if that was not
enough.
The high price of officers and business
buildings has caused many companies and
too many investments do you end up in
other cities if the Powell river delta
such Shenzhen,
which poses problems for the future,
but that is a whole of year that we
could do another time.
But anyway,
it's a viewer.
That's how things are in the city.
This until now has been one of the most
prominent beacons of prosperity and
freedom in Asia.
Only the future is going to tell us
whether this will continue to be,
and you know what?
We're going to be keeping a very close
tie her official politic,
but now it's your turn.
Do you think that Hong Kong's
authorities should encourage growth by
increasing the supply of real estate?
Well,
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey.
I don't really hope you enjoyed this
video.
Please do hit that like us,
and if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday.
Also,
don't forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media
podcasts,
they provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine and as always,
thank you for watching.